I chose to do radiation therapy before finding out about your clinic and I had a terrible side effects.
Is there anything I could do to help with these or detox from that?
Yeah, I think it really sent me back.
So we have radiation, holy opac, we have one that we create in our office.
It's just called radiation, holy opac and we have another one from PHP called Raidelin.
I think it's called.
You can take both of those.
Other key layers and other binders will help pull that out of your body.
But to help with the side effects, you have to heal whatever the damage was.
Let's say if you did radiation to the breast and it affected your heart, you're going to have to do some things to help heal heart tissue.
If you did, if you had radiation, the breast would help the lung.
You would do something different to help lung tissue if you had radiation the prostate and it damaged your colon wall, your rectal wall, then you'd have to do things to help heal that.
So it depends on where the damage is.
So you're going to have to do damage control to whatever, you know, whatever was injured by the therapy.
But as far as detoxing radiation, because radiation can stay in your system for a long, long time forever basically and continue to do damage.
So detoxing from that is important as well.
So yeah, so contact me if that's wherever this was and we can talk about some different things depending on what damage is done.